homeowners okay you could be soon paying
higher property taxes and not even
realizing it yes you need to do some
checking we've already done this this
morning i'm good now you have a few
weeks left to make your changes all you
have to do is send back a postcard that
you should have already gotten from the
clark county assessor bianca holman is
crunching the numbers for us to explain
how to check your rate bianca good
morning to you
hey good morning john good morning
heather so if your property is your
primary residence or if it's a rental
property that follows those hud
guidelines then you would qualify for
the up to three percent uh tax increase
there so here's a little bit more about
tax cap abatement for a lot of people
who are new to the area and haven't
heard of that before so remember you can
only have one primary residence listed
when you mail back that postcard the
assessor captures the data in tax cap
rate but it's the treasurer who
determines your taxes what your taxes
are going to be based on the tax cap
rate so you can verify your information
by putting in your address on the clark
county treasurer's website but the clark
county assessor warns that if that your
rate could increase up to the maximum if
you don't return that card
if the card is not returned to our
office
what can happen is you could possibly be
taxed at
the higher rate which is up to eight
percent
but that is okay once you receive your
tax bill and you realize on your tax
bill
that you don't have the appropriate tax
cap you can call our office
so checking online only takes a few
minutes if you notice an error quickly
call their office and then they'll mail
you a form you fill it out return it and
they'll be able to clear everything up
and get you back at that up to three
percent rate reporting live bianca
holman live local now